fifty percent of finance is knowledge
the other half
behavioral what are you actually gonna
do about it so let's get our knowledge
on so here are the three
most anticipated ipos and new listings
hitting the market in the coming months
and they're coming in hot
you know that song coming in hot yeah oh
we got a sales guy leah martinez shout
out leo coming in hot i only know it's a
leo it's a great song i think it's andy
mineo coming in hot so here's the three
most anticipated ipos let's start with
number one this is where i do my grocery
shopping do i just roll up to publix or
you know to sam's or to costco no
i'm busy bro
you can find me on instacart boom and
that's number one so instacart if you're
not familiar with is like uber for your
groceries right so their ipo is hitting
the market in the coming months in q4 of
2021. we're already in q4 in case you
didn't notice that start in october and
they have a valuation of 40
billion dollars that's a 40 billion
dollar home delivery grocery service
shout out to them they're like the
amazon or uber for groceries so they're
the largest grocery delivery service in
the united states of america
right their business model
centers around groceries delivered in an
hour now their mission quote unquote is
to create a world where everyone has
access to the food they love and more
time to enjoy it together i gotta tell
you i'm a fan of instacart i use
instacart
my favorite part about instacart
is you can talk to the shopper chat with
the shopper yeah and if they're doing a
good job they'll replace stuff they'll
tell you hey we don't have this this was
buy one get one but it's actually no
it's not happening cool man great great
and then you can
every time that they've screwed up
every single time
they've reimbursed or taken it off my
account like i didn't have to pay for it
and it's just been a class act it's been
a good service this is not sponsored by
instagram no it's not it's not just like
the first segment wasn't sponsored by
mint but when people are doing the the
right thing you got to show love and
show respect so shout out to instagram
do you ever use instacart i've used
instagram once yeah and uh it was an all
right experience it was just all right i
only used it once i saw i can't really
you know judge them on that but my stuff
was late
okay well maybe not but shout out
instagram i've heard great reviews yeah
like how much better is the world
because of amazon i mean look bezos gets
a bad rap oh my god he's going to the
moon he's waiting
like
it
how much better how much more convenient
is it because there's convenience things
is better time is money yeah i mean it
depends on who you ask do you use amazon
i i'm a prime member okay buddy
don't be talking trash oh i'm not
talking trash okay i'm just saying all
right well that's number one instacart
is coming to the market
in a market near you oh yeah supermarket
uh number two on this list
is reddit
reddit now what do you think of reddit
what comes to mind david uh the front
page of the internet viral videos um
the suggestions and advice for the
weirdest topics
obviously reddit when i think of reddit
clearly yeah um but obviously the
gamestop wall street bets reddit page
fiasco drama oh i think that earlier
this year okay well they're going public
basically everything that happened oh no
everything everything that happened
with the wall street bets amc gamestop
all that yeah has only helped their
stock of course not stock yet that
helped our evaluation well yeah totally
so they have an ipo coming out early in
2022 so it's not going to be this year
it's coming out you know q1 so in the
coming months basically three months
away yeah they currently have a
valuation of 15 billion dollars so in
august reddit
they raised 700 million dollars okay to
build its business and attract new
customers reddit made obviously major
noise we talked about the gamestop drama
um
and all these meme stock investors
getting in on the action wall street
bets that's what i think put it on to
the front page i don't think if reddit
was ever front page news until wall
street bets and all that kind of stuff
showed up
right sure yeah i don't know if it was
front big shoes but it's very like a
subculture thing where yeah everyone
knew about it but maybe not talked about
enough boom subculture yeah subculture
you know
indie culture right yeah yeah yes yeah
it's like right but now
when you hit when you hit you know stock
market new york stock exchange yeah
that's mainstream i don't know if
they're going to be on the nysc or
nasdaq but they're they're getting out
there are you going to be investing in
um
the reddit ipo no be interesting i'm not
i'm not i mean unless they're part of
the s p 500 or i have an index fund or
an etf
we know that i don't i don't buy
individual stocks all that often
um the only question is because what
happens with the stock is it gonna end
up going to the moon
right or somebody gonna be left holding
the bag of the reddit bag that uh that
crashes i don't know that's interesting
so that's why i invest in the s p 500
and the nasdaq and certain indexes yeah
so that's a reddit coming to the market
soon last but not least this is an app
that i actually use that i encourage
people to use and this is acorns aka
acorns grow you familiar with this app i
am i've seen the action coacher ad on
youtube boom they got a lot of
celebrities going on uh
marketing this ad so basically acorns
is basically investing for lazy people
you know it's investing for people who
don't want to think about investing and
they can just round up every purchase
and to the nearest dollar and then just
invest the spare change yeah that's what
it is it's easy i agree with um
our boy what's his uh
what was his name you interviewed him
meet kevin me kevin where he did say
he's like oh you associate investing
with spending
wholeheartedly agree that's the problem
but it's better than nothing
like if you're not doing your 401k if
you're not doing your roth ira get a you
know if you're not going to open up a
vanguard card or a vanguard account
fidelity or a target date or whatever at
least you can get started with acorns
it's it's it's again for lazy people
yeah right it the the problem with it i
agree
is that you do associate investing with
spending money yeah and it's the exact
opposite
behavioral yeah psychology that's the
whole mantra of save that money
and how much money can you really
save slash invest when you're rounding
up purchases right 40 cents here 20
cents here 80 cents here whatever it is
um
but again it's better than nothing
better than nothing
so anyway here's their story you know so
the the first two companies were an ipo
initial public offering this is going to
come to the market in a spec in q4 you
know what a spac is
no unless we're teaching david now it's
it's basically a special
purpose
acquisition company they call it a blank
check company so basically they
these specs they they it's a shell
company okay that they raise money they
don't even know where what the comp the
future company will be but they raise
the capital and then they plug in the
future
company essentially what it'll be for
the everyday investor it's literally
irrelevant who gives a but you just
learned what a spac was okay special
purpose acquisition company
aka a blank check company they start
this shell company and then they just
you know it's like kind of like three
card monthly boom they moved the company
in and this company is just gonna happen
to be acorns and it's gonna be listed on
the um the nasdaq under the ticker oaks
o-a-k-s you know what a ticker symbol is
yeah ticker symbol like
you know it's like the code name okay
that's where you can find the the the
stock yeah like facebook isn't facebook
it's right fb right there's a periodic
table of uh
periodic table of elements of stocks
this guy's getting good so they
currently have a valuation of 2.2
billion and here's their revenue in 2020
71 million not bad and by 2023 2023 they
expect revenue to cross
300 million in the next two years and
they want to grow their user base to up
to eight million users all right so
again if you're not familiar with acorns
they got all the celebrities the ashton
kutchers of the world the rock kevin
durant invested uh a-rod and j-lo when
they were
you know doing their thing they invested
in the mic and
in
acorns and basically it's it's micro
investing it's the spare change it's not
a big deal
uh and then it's also robo investing you
don't have to do anything the robot's
got this thing it's for the masses yeah
right you know the
the super wealthy people of the world
aren't exactly doing acorns yeah um
other than the celebrities that are
investing in it or promoting it but
everyday investors if you want to get
started
why not um
oh
wait that just woke me up so look i
don't again i don't typically invest in
ipos i'm not recommending that you
invest in these ipos but it is good to
be aware that these companies are coming
to market soon
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken